the owner of a youth dance studio asking
for your help to find a new home we're
talking about maximum energy Dance
Academy which is on East Lake Mead near
Pecos and it's struggling now with sort
of a changing area and it's impacting
those who train there 8 news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough stopped by
the studio to see their struggle
maximum energy Dance Academy has been in
North Las Vegas for two years and having
just lost their director about two
months ago they're doing everything they
can to try and keep up it's like a home
away from home before we leave all I do
is practice and practice and practice
Kareem Spencer along with owner Marlon
Harrington say they also need a new
location to train we want to expand and
we need to help
from overcrowding due to so many kids
wanting to join dancing in small spaces
to the homeless camping out on the side
of their building there are numerous
problems we're on a very busy
intersection so it's hard for us to
really be able to practice outside and
you know without it being a safety
concern especially the parents they
trust me to leave their children with me
every day Dance Mom Stephanie Felton is
the one who directly reached out to 8
news now explaining how much the Dance
Academy impacts her life I just
explained to Marlon the other day that I
come here sometimes to get away from my
own house I mean I'm always here because
I don't want to be home but um it means
a lot to me the hope is that maximum
energy Dance Academy will find some
sponsors and be able to expand thus
creating that safe space for the kids so
they can dance safely once again just
because we're in North Las Vegas doesn't
mean that we really have to suffer
there's a lot more buildings and
opportunities here and you know owners
that could possibly help us to expand on
visions
[Applause]
energy dancer Dance Academy's next
competition by the way is set for this
summer and their hope is to maybe move
into a new space as early as July their
GoFundMe will be attached to the story
on our website for those who may want to
help and donate